[Musique]
mon invité à la politique dans le sang à
10 ans à peine il voulait devenir maire
de sa commune à 18 ans il a pris sa
carte à l'UMP pour finalement rejoindre
le rassemblement
[Musique]
national bonjour Kevin mauvieux bonjour
alors la toute première prise de parole
d'un député dans ici que c'est rarement
une partie de plaisir il y a souvent la
voix qui tremble la bouche qui est sèche
la sueur qui perle au front et puis
quand on a des des notes à la main on
voit la feuille qui tremble alors j'ai
voulu voir comment ça s'était passé pour
vous j'ai retrouvé les images c'était
pendant le projet de loi sur le pouvoir
d'achat face à la France
insoumise permettez-moi de vous renommer
le groupe enfumage parce que vous
prétendez défendre le pouvoir d'achat
des Français et en réalité ça fait pas
très longtemps qu'on a commencé à voter
mais tout ce qui va dans dans le sens du
pouvoir d'achat vous votez contre vous
êtes là encore une fois pour faire le
cirque faire un maximum d'amendements
être visible mais les électeurs ne s'y
tromperont pas les électeurs vous voient
et vous entendent et il voi aujourd'hui
que vous êtes contre tout ce qui peut
augmenter le pouvoir d'achat que ce soit
vos mesures ou pas vous votez contre et
c'est inadmissible alors vous parlez
sans notes vous avez la voix qui est qui
est parfaitement posée vous sembler
vraiment très à l'aise comme si vous
aviez fait ça toute votre vie alors non
j'ai pas fait ça toute ma vie mais mais
vous avez des prédispositions pour pour
vous exprimer en public ou bah peut-être
peut-être que dans la nature de chacun
on a tous une prédisposition pour
quelque chose des personnes sont plus
artistiques que d'autres peut-être que
j'ai plus effectivement une
prédisposition pour prendre la parole
devant devant un public estce que vous
aviez pas de vraie carrière politique en
fait avant ce jour-là avant votre
élection à l'Assemblée vous avez eu un
engagement local dont on va parler hein
mais comme simple conseiller municipal
d'opposition en fait là ce qui a fait je
pense la réussite de cette prise de
parole c'est que j'ai juste parlé avec
mes tripes en fait quand on m'a proposé
d'être candidat aux élections
législatives euh j'ai je me suis posé la
question j'ai réfléchi et j'ai toujours
été motivé par mes convictions j'ai
toujours défendu au sein de ma famille
mon entourage mes convictions et donc ce
jour-là effectivement j'étais dépassé
par le fait de pas pouvoir agir pour les
Français par une nupess qui bloquait et
en fait je pense que c'est ça c'est que
je me suis levé et et j'ai parlé avec
mes tripes donc pas besoin de papier
c'est sorti tout seul alors visiblement
c'est première prise de parole est pas
passé inaperçu parce que très rapidement
dans les jours qu'on suivi on a commencé
à vous voir à la radio à la télé alors
qu'il y avait une consigne très claire
he qui avait été donné au sein du groupe
rassemblement national c'était que les
petits nouveaux devaient se faire
discret le temps d'apprendre un peu le
métier et devaient laisser la parole à
ceux qui s'était déjà engagé au côté de
Marine Le Pen dans son équipe de
campagne à la présidentielle qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé on vous a donné un bon
de sortie B je ne sais pas si c'est un
bon de sortie mais effectivement elle a
rentrée au mois dep septembre on est
venu vers moi me proposer voilà est-ce
que tu veux tenter les médias tu as une
bonne prise de parole dans l'hémicycle
c'estàd que vous avez été repéré quand
même à ce moment-là ou je oui oui oui
certainement ben de toute façon j'avais
eu des compliments après cette prise de
parole et après les quelques prises de
paroles que j'avais faites pendant ce
texte pouvoir d'achat en juillet juste
après l'élection j'avais eu quelques
compliments effectivement qui m'avaient
été remontés et que j'avais surpris par
ma façon où mon aisance a parlerit dans
l'hémicycle aussi rapidement et donc
effectivement on m'a proposé voilà au
mois de septembre est-ce que tu veux
tester les média on a commencé par une
petite radio on a commencé avec LCP et
puis ça a fonctionné et de là de fil en
aiguille j'ai fait un peu plus de médias
et ce qui a abouti à ma nomination
porte-parole du groupe rassemblement
national d'ailleurs le le vendredi du
weekend des estivals à ber al si on va
être tout à fait exact vous avez quand
même fait des apparitions télé avant de
devenir député mais c'était dans un
autre registre c'était en tant que
candidat à des jeux télés vous avez
commencé par le juste prix avec la gaff
il y a eu ensuite les 12 coups de midi
que le meilleur gagne tout le monde veut
prendre sa place est-ce que quelque part
vous aimez pas un peu prendre la lumière
non ça n'a rien à voir avec prendre la
lumière et pour comprendre pourquoi j'ai
fait tous ces jeux pour être très clair
c'est qu'effectivement j'ai commencé
vous l'avez dit avec le jeu de Vincent
laaff Le juste prix parce que ben j'ai
grandi dans une famille populaire comme
il en existe des millions en France et
on se retroua devant le Big Deal quand
j'étais enfant on regardait le Big Deal
le soir et donc j'ai toujours eu envie
de jouer avec Vincent Lagaffe je
trouvais ça drôle j'ai grandi avec et
quand j'ai eu 18 ans Vincent lagf ne
faisait plus le Big Deal mais le juste
prix je me suis dit pour déconner je
vais particip puis j'ai été pris pour
une raison j'ignore j'ai été pris j'ai
participé j'ai perdu et ce qu'on ne sait
pas avant d'entrer dans ce milieu c'est
que quand vous faites un jeu et que vous
êtes plutôt apprécié sur le plateau
directeur casting vous en propose
d'autres derrière en et c'est comme ça
que ça s fait j'en ai fait d'autr vous
savez vousêes pas le seul député avoir
fait des jeux télé c'est possible il y
en a un qui en a fait même plus que vous
c'est Carl olive qui est passé dans
cette émission avant vous on a retrouvé
même des images de lui à l'époque sauf
que lui son but c'était de faire des
jeux pour remplacer l'animateur mais bon
ah oui d'accord non moi j'en étais pas
mais vous avez un autre point commun
avec Carl olive c'est que vous avez tous
les deux un père qui a été ouvrier vous
avez tous les deux grandi dans un un
milieu populaire c'est quelque chose que
vous avez déjà évoqué hein il y a
quelques instants que vous assumez que
vous revendiquez même bah je le
revendique dans la mesure où c'est pas
forcément le cas de toute la classe
politique mais après on ne choisit pas
d'où on vient et je le revendique dans
le sens où je trouve que c'est une force
par exemple je vais présenter dans la
niche du rassemblement national un texte
pour apporter un complément de revenu
aux étudiants qui travaillent ben c'est
une force parce que combien de députés
dans l'hémicycle seraiit capable de
porter cette loi en l'ayant vécu moi je
l'ai vécu j'ai dû travailler pour payer
mes études alors vous avez exercé des
métiers très différents avant d'arriver
à l'Assemblée nationale vous avez été
caissier dans un supermarché pour payer
vos études vous avez été vendeur de
voiture animateur d'attraction à eurod
Disney conseiller bancaire agent
d'assurance est-ce qu'il y a un point
commun à tous ces métiers le point
commun c'est le lien avec les gens alors
certes c'est un lien différentelon les
métiers quand vous êtes à la caisse bon
vous êtes pas commercial mais il y a
quand même un lien vous aidez les gens
mine de rien quand vous êtes caissé vous
êtes aussi une oreille attentive parce
que vous avez plein de personnes souvent
des personnes âgées qui n'ont que vous
comme contact dans la journée qui vont
venir vous raconter un peu leur vie Euro
Disney bon bah Euro Disney c'est pareil
c'est du contact c'est du spectacle mais
c'est du contact en permanence est-ce
qu'il y a pas aussi un un côté vendeur
commercial besoin de alors après ouais
convaincre il a il y a un fil rouge dans
tout ça et qu'on retrouve y compris dans
le rôle de député au final c'est
effectivement l'envie de convaincre et
et moi je fais par on doit vendre des
assurances quand on est doit vendre des
voit exactement et je fais partie de
ceux qui je sais que tout le monde ne le
pense pas mais je fais partie de ceux
quand j'étais commercial qui disaient
toujours que un bon commercial enfin
pour être un bon commercial il faut
aimer le produit qu'on vend euh parce
que le but c'est de convaincre les gens
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs la voiture je
l'ai pas fait très longtemps parce que
j'étais pas un fan de voiture
l'assurance j'aimais le produit et là
aujourd'hui je suis tellement convaincu
par mes idées par ce que je défends que
j'aime aller au contact et j'aime
convaincre effectivement c'est un fil
rouge he de bout en bout alors vous avez
commencé à vous intéresser à la
politique dès la primaire vous vous êtes
fixé à l'époque un objectif assez
surprenant vouliez devenir maire de
votre commune Ponteau de M qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui vous faisait rêver dans
l'idée de de devenir maire c'était pas
forcément du rêve euh parce que rêve
c'est un grand mot je voulais pas être
maire pour être mire mais je voulais
être maire parce que j'avais déjà dès
l'école cette appétence pour être
délégué de classe et cetera et je
voulais défendre les gens je voulais
améliorer le quotidien et ponte de mer
c'est je suis né là-bas j'ai toujours
vécu là-bas c'est une ville que j'ai
dans le cœur que j'aime et que j'ai
toujours voulu améliorer et donc bah dès
mes 10 an alors que j'étais dans un
milieu où on était pas très politisé dès
mes 10 ans je me disais mais je seraiis
mère j'ai telle ambition pour ma ville
et alors à 15 ans vous avez été séduit
par Nicolas Sarkozi et sont travailler
plus pour gagner plus he la
présidentielle de 2007 à 18 ans vous
avez pris votre carte à l'UMP pourquoi
l'UMP et pas le le FN à l'époque bah
parce que à l'époque j'étais séduit par
le le discours de l'UMP le discours de
Nicolas Sarkozi qui était un vrai
discours de droite qui était un discours
de fermeté d'autorité qui mettait la
valeur travail au premier plan avec le
fameux travailler plus pour gagner plus
qui m'avait beaucoup séduit euh on le
disait j'ai grandi dans un milieu
modeste ouvrier femme de ménage pour mes
parents bah c'est un milieu où
effectivement j'ai appris qu'on avait
rien sans rien et qu'il fallait
travailler pour gagner de l'argent et
donc j'ai toujours eu envie de mettre la
valeur travail au centre donc c'est
cette campagne de de Nicolas Sarkozi
travailler plus pour gagner plus qui
m'avait attiré en fait alors vous avez
milité au sein des républicains jusqu'en
2020 2021 à peu près vous avez été élu
conseiller municipal de ponto de mer
Laur voquier vous a même félicité pour
un de vos discours lors d'un meeting
qu'est-ce qui vous a éloigné de la
droite finalement bah ce qui m'a éloigné
de la droite et de LR c'est leur
rapprochement avec la macronie tout
simplement quand Emmanuel Macron est
arrivé au pouvoir moi dès le début j'ai
dit que j'étais un opposant ferme
d'Emmanuel Macron qui était le
représentant indirect de François
Hollande je sentais un petit peu cette
arrogance qui naissait dans ce parti et
mais les LR ont quand même continué à
entretenir des relation et je suis dans
un département l'heure où on a Bruno Le
Maire Sébastien le Cornu une région o on
a Édouard Philippe d'anciens membres de
de la droite qui ont rejoin qui ont
rejoint Emmanuel Macron qui n'ont pas
forcément fait l'objet d'attaque
virulente du parti par rapport à leur
départ et à un moment on était les l
sont devenus tellement proches de la
macronie et on le voit aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée nationale que je pouvais pas
rester dans ce parti alors vous avez
rejoint le rassemblement national assez
tardivement c'était je crois au mois de
février 2022 donc quelques mois avant
les
Législatives vu de l'extérieur ça peut
donner l'impression d'une forme
d'opportunisme vous avez pas forcément
obtenu ce que vous vouliez du côté des
républicains vous êtes allé voir le RN
qui cherchait des candidats aux
législatives non parce que si j'avais
rejoint le RN pour les élections déjà
j'y serais allé je pense plusut tôt
parce que y aller en février 4 mois
avant l'élection c'est un peu fort de
café euh et je les aurais rejoint dès
que j'ai quitté LR en réalité j'ai
quitté LR pour les raisons que je viens
de vous citer le RN j'ai attendu avant
de le rejoindre parce que je voulais
quand même m'imprégner du programme je
voulais quand même même euh m'assurer
que tout ce que les médias vendent sur
le RN était faux et une fois que tout ça
a été fait février 2022 je suis arrivé à
l'aboutissement et j'imaginais pas du
tout être candidat aux élections
législatives je voulais juste participer
à la campagne de Marine qui me semblait
être la meilleure pour incarner le le la
France d'aujourd'hui euh mais il y avait
absolument aucune envie derrière en
rejoignant leur Assemblée nationale et
honnêtement il y a il y a un an et demi
qui pouvait dire qu'il y aurait des des
départements comme l'heur qui
basculeraiit au rassemblement
grand compr donc çaurait pas été un très
bon calcul alors vous expliquez que vous
faites de la politique pour aider les
gens sauf qu'aujourd'hui vous siégez bah
dans l'opposition vous vous sentez utile
malgré tout en tant que député on se
sent utile parce que même si c'est pas
directement nos amendements ou
directement nos propositions qui sont
voter en réalité on est suffisamment
nombreux en étant le premier groupe
d'opposition pour mettre une pression
sur le gouvernement et pour au final
réussir à imposer quelques idées la
remise carburant l'année dernière si
elle est arrivée c'est parce qu'on a mis
la pression le gouvernement n'avait pas
envie de faire une remise carburant
leschecs qui ont été distribué pour
aider les gens qui se chauffent au bois
ou au fou c'est la même chose et là plus
récemment le harcèlement scolaire
Gabriel Atal qui on fait son cheval de
bataille qui a demandé à partir de la
rentrée à ce que les harceleurs soient
changé d'école au lieu que ce soit la
victime qui change d'école ben c'est ma
proposition de loi que j'ai déposé au
printemps donc si vous voulez on ne vote
pas nos textes parce que ça fait pas
bien mais en réalité il s'en inspire
comme la l'interdiction de la BAA voilà
tout ça c'est des textes qui viennent du
RN des idées qui viennent du RN qui sont
bonnes et de bon sens et qui finissent
par aboutir on va passer à notre quiz à
présent euh je vous explique le principe
je commence une phrase et c'est à vous
de la
compléter être le premier Kevin élu à
l'Assemblée
c'est c'est je suis le premier et demi
parce qu'on est rentré à deux en même
temps oui mais euh c'est gratifiant et
et c'est valorisant ça permet de montrer
que en France l'escalier social
fonctionne toujours l'escalier pas
l'ascenseur c'estàdire queand donc c'est
quand même un symbole signifiant pour
vous ah pour moi c'est un symbole
signifiant Kevin Jordan ce sont des
prénoms qu' ont longtemps été associés à
des classes modestes et populaires j'en
suis pas très convaincu mais en tout cas
ça l'a toujours été associé et donc je
suis persuadé que c'est le symbole que
quand on se donne les moyens qu'on veut
monter sur l'escalier de la de
l'ascension sociale on peut le faire si
j'étais devenu gendarme alors j'explique
c'est que vous aviez passé le concours
de l'école de gendarmerie vous l'aviez
réussi mais finalement vous y avez
renoncé et ben si j'étais devenu
gendarme il y a grande Chan que je ne
serai pas là aujourd'hui puisqu'on ne
peut pas faire les deux en même temps
exactement mais il y a aussi de grandes
chances vu le contexte actuel
malheureusement euh il y a de grandes
chances que j'aurais démissionné
peut-être même pour m'engager en
politique et pour essayer de défendre un
peu plus le corps des forces de l'ordre
et de la gendarmerie qui aujourd'hui est
trop délaissé enfin l'assemblée c'est
comme un jeu télé oh là là l'assemblée
c'est comme un jeu télé il y a des
caméras et des micros euh mais alors par
contre à l'issue ce qui est à gagner
c'est pas une vitrine c'est l'avenir de
la France et ben ce sera le mot de la
fin Merci à VOUS monu d'être venu dans
la politique et moi merci à merci
[Musique]
beaucoup